[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
mike florio's new book playmakers how
the nfl really works and doesn't now
available online wherever books are sold
and it's the best bestseller here florio
joining us in the news yesterday is
bruce arians in uh one of his last
things that he said as the head coach of
the buccaneers called out florio and
said that uh well go ahead you can write
about it mike um what did you make of
bruce arians yesterday
you know i'm sitting there minding my
own business dan in my office working on
pft
got a a window open with the buccaneers
press conference and i mean if i'd had a
mouthful of water or coffee or well it
was too early to have anything stronger
than that i would have spit it all over
the computer screen i couldn't believe
it and look i
i i like it i it just shows that they
read and they heed and they listen and
they pay attention and
i'm sure he's not thrilled with my
speculation
somewhat informed
discussion of
how this all came to be but any any
chance that his
you know the way he announces retirement
is actually
real like it's true
well when does this ever happen first of
all it's the first time since jimmy
johnson
left the cowboys in march of 1994 that a
coach has exited this late in the cycle
none of it adds up he was all in he was
at the scouting combine he was involved
he was involved in free agency and the
idea that tom brady coming back caused
him to say now's the time to leave of
anything it would cause him to say now's
the time to stay
i was worried about what we're going to
do without tom brady now tom brady is
back and 17 days after this was the key
for me dan
17 days after tom brady ends a 40-day
retirement bruce erins is out
and there's never even the most remote
suggestion that tom brady is troubled by
that
doesn't that tell us kind of everything
we need to know and i think we're
underrating what bruce arians means to
the football team on game day but the
fundamental problem here i think arose
from the fact that ariens wasn't
involved with the team most of the time
and that he would show up and
become involved and at a certain point
the folks who are grinding every day
busting their asses every day are going
to resent that and i think that's where
some of this professional friction came
from doesn't mean there's personal
friction you know the aryans fall back
is we get along fine well there's been
plenty of people i've worked with over
the years that i love them personally
professionally i just can't work with
you anymore it's possible that those two
things can exist
what do you think happened when brady
went to london
something
and it was so funny he puts out that
video of cristiano ronaldo saying you're
done right he's like
and two hours later he's back i mean he
knew damn well what he was doing i think
he retired and this is a take that sims
and i have
kind of come up with after talking about
it way too often over the past few
months the retirement wasn't something
that he was forced into his dad says
well you know espn reported he's
retiring so he had to retire like like
that's going to be a real factor in your
life decision to retire
i think he actively explored whether or
not he could pull off
a move to another team the dolphins were
looking at sean payton and tom brady
together that's not happening if tom
brady isn't at least interested in the
possibility of partnering up with sean
payton those thoughts aren't being had
and entertained and acted upon by the
dolphins who admit that they called the
saints to inquire about the availability
of sean payton and we're told don't even
waste your time by
former dolphins gm jeff ireland who's
now the assistant gm in new orleans so
i think part of that 40 days was
is there another place i can continue my
career and one of the benefits of being
tom brady is you never have to order the
code red you never have to dirty your
hands with
gee i'd really like to come back but i'm
not happy with the coaching situation
that's something that happens three
levels down
gets communicated three levels down from
ownership of the buccaneers and it works
its way up and people you know jason
light said yesterday on rich eisen show
tom never made a demand of course he
didn't make a demand if you're tom brady
you don't have to make a demand it's one
of the benefits of being tom brady
is it your feeling or is it reporting
well i think it's a combination of both
and i think that's kind of where we are
in today's world when you're plugged
into the matrix 24 hours a day like i am
and you've been doing it for 20 years
you get an idea of what's really going
on for example when pete carroll tells
the world we have no intention to trade
russell wilson my first reaction was
there's a for sale sign folks they're
willing to trade him and i had all these
seahawks fans and seahawks media you're
crazy you're nuts your high your
whatever and then what happened a week
later they have a deal to trade him to
the denver broncos so you develop a
sense of what the patterns are what the
trends are what the truth is and what
the bs is
and this one is so weird in comparison
to everything else we've seen in the
last 20 years or the last 40 years or
the last 50 years there's got to be
smoke there and where there's smoke as
we often know there's fire i had some
seattle fans who blamed me
for russell wilson getting traded
because i had him on and he did that
interview where he kind of aired his his
laundry and i went
all i did is ask a question normally
russ doesn't give you anything of great
detail
and he gave me a whole lot there and
then i followed up and that's why i said
all along i thought we were going to
have something similar to what we had
with the rams and the lions where
matthew stafford and the lions would
mutually agree what's best for both is
to divorce and that's exactly what
happened in that situation we're talking
to mike florio the book is playmakers
available online wherever books are sold
so brady gets what he wants i guess with
todd bowles the only thing that i'll
i'll leave you with this one item
does bruce arians have the autonomy to
pick his successor
i mean that's what was surprising that
it feels like ownership would say we
kind of want to know you know what what
our plan is down the road
bruce said hey i wanted to have todd
bowles and i'm all for todd bowles
getting another chance i just didn't
know that bruce would have
that say that power to name his
successor well look if what we're being
told is true and obviously i have my
doubts bruce arians put ownership in a
very tough spot by walking away when he
did because if i own a football team i
would at least like to know as soon as
possible after the season ends that i'm
going to be looking for a coach because
i was i would at least like to have the
opportunity to cast a wider net and
consider my options maybe i come back to
todd bowles at the end of the day but
i'd at least like to have the chance to
try what else are you going to do if
you're the buccaneers and your head
coach leaves on march 30 you're going to
start a search then you can't under the
rules no team is required to let you
talk to any of their assistants under
contract because march 1 is when that
window closes that's why the rooney rule
doesn't apply that's a loophole by the
way that i think they're going to close
because i as soon as i as soon as i saw
that the rooney rule doesn't apply to
any vacancies after march 1. i thought
oh boy jerry jones is going to fire mike
mccarthy after march 1 and hire sean
payton or elevate dan quinn now that
jerry jones knows this exists because
it's the first time it's ever happened
he's going to use it and they're going
to close that loophole before he can all
right before i let you go
the baker mayfield story seems pretty
quiet
is it going to stay that way for until
the draft or after the draft
i think both of these teams that are
looking to trade veteran quarterbacks
with significant salaries the 49ers with
jimmy garoppolo and the browns of baker
mayfield i think they want to wait at
this point to see what happens with the
draft if there's going to be maybe a
team that is targeting a quarterback
round one or two if they don't get him
then maybe a trade market emerges at
some point though it gets very awkward
because you can't lock the guy out of
the facility if he wants to show up and
if i'm baker mayfield deal with me i'm
not going to go sit in the corner you
got to deal with me or you got to cut me
these even though these guys don't have
no trade clauses you have a lot of power
when you're a starting quarterback if a
team is going to trade for you and you
don't want to go there good luck getting
that team to give up any significant
assets for that contract that could be a
mess for any team that tries to trade
for garoppolo or mayfield mayfield's got
a ton of power also because his salary
is fully guaranteed he's getting 18.8
million this year no matter what so it's
a mess for the browns and for the 49ers
it's going to be one of the fun story
lines to keep an eye on as the offseason
continues also with the rams with bobby
wagner i was just thinking of that they
keep kicking the salary cap down the
road signing these guys that you know
they don't need draft picks here
uh but
bobby wagner's signing um i i thought it
was a great pickup i don't know cost
wise if it is but this plan the rams
keep buying into it uh your thoughts on
wagner well two things five years 50
million i mean how many times do we have
to hear the big number yeah
and then see the real numbers and see
the details and understand what the deal
really is before we become skeptical of
the big number i'm skeptical of five
years 50 million but
five years
spreads it out more under the cap and
here's the thing to remember about the
cap dollars
it goes up every year
so a million dollars in cap space this
year
means a lot more to a team than a
million dollars in cap space next year
because the cap's going to be higher
it's a smaller percentage that's why
teams kick it forward because the cap's
going to keep going up and down with the
gambling money with the tv contracts
cap's going to be 300 million before we
know it so that's why these teams do it
and if you're the rams and you hey aaron
donald on the line bobby wagner
linebacker jayla ramsey at corner we're
sleeping on the rams so much talk last
year about the buccaneers repeating why
aren't we talking about the rams
repeating all the talents left the nfc
the packers are down the bucks are still
going through a coaching change we take
for granted how good bruce arians is on
game day they could be down a little bit
and here are the rams they're right
where they left off and i think we need
to be thinking about them as a team that
gets back to the super bowl and maybe
wins it again i'll tell bruce aryans you
said hello please do thank you mike have
a great weekend the book is playmakers
it's great book
how the nfl really works and doesn't
available online wherever books are sold